they already know what I can do I know
you're a source of document enough
documentary so I know what ask new
badges you're not there yeah not very I
just need you not push you know you know
you're here because you know I'm right
of course yes I can say like maybe
tonight tonight where I'm like just do
it
[ __ ] them but the truth is even if you
feel the high for me I'm like so if I'd
miraculously came up with an amazing
thing to say to you right now
the truth is next Thursday happens and
I'm not here so what I would say is the
fact that you even know I'm right so you
understand the reason people leave
negative comments on me
or they don't like me some people here
didn't like didn't like me at first is
because I'm not letting you get away
with your [ __ ] I'm getting to the
point of it and the people that don't
like me are the ones that want to pay
other people or want other people that
show them Lamborghinis or watches they
want to they want to trick them they
want to trick them into feeling good
there's only work there's only not
caring about everybody else you know
what to do you grew up in a way
environment parents DNA that hasn't let
you get there yet but the fact that
you're even here and you basically said
what you have to do to me I didn't say
anything yeah yeah it's just a matter of
time now what you need to do is keep
pressure on it
the reason I never change my tune is the
reason I'm getting so many people to do
things is because I don't waver it's
constant offense I'm going to pound you
every day every day multiple times a day
with the same [ __ ] thing it never
changes it's the same thing luckily for
me there's new platforms so it feels
like I'm saying something new because
shits changing but it's the same thing
it's the same thing and you'll just
eventually get there what you need to do
is you need to keep paying attention to
people like me or others that sound like
me so that it becomes your norm it
becomes your oxygen there is no other
voices and eventually just like when you
jump off a diving board to a pool just
like when you kiss somebody for the
first time just like anything else you
ever did in life eventually you get
there and you do it and you never look
back you understand yeah so the key the
key is to suffocate yourself into
pressuring yourself to have no other
options
okay the least mom worth listening to is
because I'll do that for you and then
you don't need me anymore thank you
yeah I don't have to sell you anything
crazy I don't want you to stay around I
just want I just just want one for you
baby yeah screaming my face just [ __ ]
do it I don't even want to do that do
you want everyone to do it I'll tell you
why I don't want you because I don't
feel it's right you know why cuz its
tactical but it's just a mental thing I
think it's know what you want me to fix
the sink I want you to picture well yeah
you understand you just want me to fix
your sink right now I don't want to do
that you already know the answer my
screaming your face will be a fun moment
they'll be cool to think back to it's
not what you need right now what you
need is constant pressure on any voice
that's penetrating you that isn't
allowing you to make that jump
well that's your mom or older brother or
your aunt or your best friend or your
girlfriend or what I don't know who the
[ __ ] that is but you need to eliminate
it you don't to cut them out like that
others like you know the cobbler when I
say cut friendship out I mean I have
friends that I don't listen to a [ __ ]
word they say that my friend but I don't
take the words as my gospel you know
what to do I heard you that's why I'm
not gonna get into I heard you I know
you're ready yeah just you know what you
are just a matter of time
[Music]